just to get some clarity on Friday the
prime minister said that people should
go back to work if you can so can you
clarify for us should people be working
from home if they can or should they be
going back to the office now we want to
see more people back at work on the shop
floor in the office wherever they can be
of course in some cases it's appropriate
and convenient for people to work from
home but we wanted to make sure that
where people can add value where the
economy can benefit from people being at
work that they are at work we want to
make sure that the economic engines of
this country are fired up again and
that's why the Chancellor made the
series of announcements that he made
earlier this week in order to make sure
that we're in a position to be able to
provide people with safety and security
at work to protect their jobs and to
guarantee jobs in the future
interesting to hear you say there that
for some people it may be more
convenient to work at home do you think
some of us have got a bit too used to
working from home no I think that
working from home of course has been for
many people an absolute requirement
during the pandemic but there are
certain jobs of course where it's
impossible to work from home you have to
be on the shop floor in order to be able
to be part of the productive economy and
to enjoy your work but I think that one
of the things the pandemic has also
taught us is that there are some roles
which can be performed effectively from
home the way in which a number of you
know social media apps and other devices
have enabled us to work from him means
that we can rethink our work in certain
ways and I know for example that within
the civil service we will increasingly
be using some of the technology that
we've used during the pandemic to think
not just about enabling people to work
from home but also enabling people to
work in areas other than London and one
of the things that we want to do is to
make sure that we distribute the the
range of civil service jobs and
responsibilities more equitably across
the whole United Kingdom so the reports
that you're thinking about moving some
of the civil sense to Yorkers crack them
well York is not the only place where we
can
redeploy some of the essential
decision-makers who form part of our
brilliant civil service we're looking at
different locations across the United
Kingdom it's already the case that there
are civil servants for example that
depart for international development in
Scotland and of course a significant
number of civil servants from the
Department for Transport in in Wales but
we wanted to make sure that across our
whole United Kingdom the power of the UK
government its capacity to make a
difference for the better is felt by
everyone so we'll be saying more in
coming months about how we can ensure
that jobs and investment and opportunity
are spread more equally across the whole
UK okay and pretty clear from your
answers so far that the government is
trying to get more people back to work
more people shopping more people eating
out to help out but of course people
aren't going to do that unless they feel
that it's safe to do so and have to say
you know the our number that we were
told was so important is it still as
high as one in pretty much every region
of England we've seen Leicester having
to go into lockdown again because of a
spike in cases the test and trace system
seems to be reaching fewer people every
week I mean you can see why people feel
that actually it might be safer to stay
at home well of course
um you raised a number of issues there I
said I'd say it's several things the
first is that we have an evolving a set
of facts about the spread of this virus
which enable us to take a more
sophisticated approach with every week
that passes in dealing with it so if
there are examples and you mention
Leicester is the most conspicuous where
we see a spike we're testing numbers
show that the rate of infection is
rising then we can take appropriate
local action to lock that down and that
inevitable restriction on freedom for
people in in Leicester does mean the
freedoms for others elsewhere can be
maintained you're also right as well
that mask-wearing in appropriate
circumstances are indoors whether that's
of course on public transport or in
retail that can help protect others if
you may be asymptomatic but capable of
spreading the infection and
taken together we also have a a test
track and trace system of increasing
sophistication and we're better able to
focus our tests on those who need it and
also better able to trace the context of
those who have been infected and well
over a hundred thousand people have been
traced in order to ensure that they do
self isolate to limit the spread of the
infection although the the concern is
that the numbers seem to be going down
so last place last week for example
2,500 people who tested positive
provided details for close contacts
leading to just over 10,000 being
reached that's down from the previous
week when 16,000 contacts were reached
is it really a system to have confidence
in yes it absolutely is there are a
number of challenges of course in making
sure that we reach those people who've
been in contact with those who test
positive and there are some specific
factors which mean that in certain areas
making sure that we can make contact is
more challenging but the the wonderful
team in in charge of this headed by Dido
Harding have been doing great work in
order to refine how the system works and
in order to make sure that if we do
notice a spike in infection in any part
of the United Kingdom that we can deal
effectively with it and there are a
number of factors which are only being
discussed and looked at at the moment
and which suggests that there are
certain parts of the country there are
certain factors on the ground that may
influence the spread of infection and of
course we are building up a better
picture all the time of what those
factors are so that we can respond more
appropriately ok talking about building
up a better picture on testing and Sky
News revealed this week that at the
height of the pandemic the government
said that the number of people that the
government said had been tested for Co
vat19 was not actually correct so on the
21st of May a government slides the
daily press conference said that over 2
million people that had been tested but
this week that a pump with a health
posted data that showed in fact on that
date only 1.8 million people had been
tested so that's 200,000 fewer people
and we were told at the time were your
apologize the misleading the public
I'm sorry I say I didn't quite hear that
question because of some background
noise could you repeat it for me please
it's a Sky News revealed this week that
at the height of the pandemic the
government overstated the number of
people who had tested positive for
coping 19 by 200,000 who have been
tested firk over nineteen sorry by over
200,000 will you apologize for
misleading the public I'm not aware of
that report okay what it's the 21st of
May government slides at the daily press
conference said two million people have
been tested this week the Department of
Health posted data that showed that in
fact on the 21st of May one point eight
million people had been tested so that's
200,000 people who you said had been
tested for Kovach 19 actually hadn't
will you apologize for misleading the
public no I certainly haven't misled
anyone it is the case of course that the
Department of Health will be responsible
for consistently correcting any figures
but I'm a completely unfamiliar with
this story so again I'm very happy to
investigate and to look at the source of
the original figures and the source of
the revised figures and to explain any
discrepancy but I'm afraid I was unaware
of this matter until you mentioned it is
it something that you will be looking
into try and get more information on
well now that you mention it I will of
course check absolutely again one of the
things that has happened throughout this
crisis is that sometimes I'm not
suggesting that's the case here people
have been comparing apples with pears so
if you look for example at the the
instance of the disease that has been
revealed through testing and then if you
look at the incidence instance of the
disease that has been estimated by
official statisticians they're obviously
different things there's a relationship
between them now here you're talking
about testing numbers I'd have to look
at the figures because as we know
they've been different types of tests
carried out here I don't know whether on
the original figure refer to the pillar
one and pillar two tests and other tests
and the subsequent figure refers only to
pillar two I'd have to look at that and
and then of course come back to you okay
well I look forward to that response
there in that case I just want to move
on to face masks because it does feel as
if you know if you go to the high street
as we're being urged to do that
North a lot of people still not wearing
face masks in restaurants in bars and in
shops as well does that need to change
should it become mandatory to wear a
face mask or a face covering in a shop
as it is in Scotland I think we should
do everything we can to encourage people
and to support people to wear face masks
in enclosed places particularly shops
and I think that it will be the case
that government will be able to help in
that regard we're investing in
significantly increasing the capacity to
manufacture face masks in the UK my
colleague in the camera office lead or
Agnew has been leading a drive to ensure
that we have face mask manufacturing
ability which is based in Wales and in
Burnley and that will make it easier for
all of us to wear face masks as
appropriate I just wonder if actually
people need to be more than encouraged
to wear face masks because you know that
the message on this has been frankly all
over the place you know that the latest
new go of data shows only 36% of us are
wearing a face mask in public places
compare that to 90% in Singapore 83% in
Italy 78% in France 65% in Germany and
it's not that surprising one until
recently you know the government
ministers and scientists have been
telling us that actually frankly they
don't much that much difference
Boris Johnson and Russia soon at both
pictured out and about this week at not
wearing face masks as themselves I mean
how can you expect the public to wear
them when you're a members of the
government on well I think there are a
number of things there that need to be
unpacked the first thing is that face
masks are appropriate in some settings
not in others you talk about people
being out and about wearing a face mask
when you are out and about outdoors is
significantly less necessary than when
you're indoors there's a distinction
there and one that's well understood by
the public and which is underpinned by
science the next point that you make was
about the decisions that individuals
make themselves well I think it's a good
thing that people do wear a face mask in
appropriate circumstances but you make
the point that right from the beginning
of this they'd been different views one
view however has been consistent and
it mustn't be the case that anyone
thinks that wearing a facemask somehow
makes them invulnerable
there was once some concern earlier on
that a message on Facebook that
suggested if everyone wore them and and
then he became mandatory might be
interpreted by some as a license to be a
little Cavalier but the evolving
evidence it's become firmer over time is
that what wearing a facemask definitely
helps you to help others in enclosed
space because we know that the the
nature of the virus the way in which it
spreads can be inhibited if you're
wearing that mask we know that the the
spread of the virus is greater and the
risk to others greater if you're in size
with poor ventilation if you're outside
significantly less all of these facts
inform a strategy which enables us to
provide people with the right advice in
the right way I just can't help but
think if the advice that I'm hearing
from you is still quite confusing you
know talking about cavalier attitude
talk about the differences of being out
and about or inside which I accept two
valid points but shouldn't you just be
going out there telling people to wear
face masks I mean the director-general
the Chinese Center for Disease Control
in March the big mistake in Europe is
that people aren't wearing masks why is
it taken this country so long just to
simply direct people with a clear
message that we should be wearing face
masks well I think people are
intelligent um I I think that people can
understand that this is a novel virus
with specific challenges there are
appropriate moments of course when a
direct message to say to people don't do
X or do do Y is appropriate but I also
think that it's quite right to treat the
British people with the respect that
their intelligence and their judgement
deserves and in this case one of the
things that I think is right is to say
outside you don't need to wear a face
mask inside particularly in an enclosed
space with poor ventilation it's
absolutely a good idea
public transport you should be wearing
it because of the necessary benefits
that it brings to others enclosed areas
like shops we encourage people to wear
face masks as well and that seems to me
to be perfectly sensible advice and
again you know that I can understand
there may be a desire to build a binary
divide in the nature of the questions
that you ask but I think it's important
to treat people with respect okay
another key part of course of the
government advice is on public transport
at the moment we're told we should only
use it as a last resort that we should
consider all other forms of transport
before using public transport if the
government is keen to get more people
back to work many people of course take
the bus or the train to work does that
advice need to change all advice under
review but I think it's important that
if people can get to work by using other
means they should and we want to
encourage people particularly as the
weather improves to walk and cycle
wherever possible but sometimes
particularly in major urban areas public
transport is the only way in which
people get to work that's why we want
people to use public transport safely
which is why of course the wearing of
masks on public transport is important
okay now just to move on to a couple of
other issues so while we still have you
firstly on the UK borders you're
announcing some more money today but we
know that there have been concerns
raised about this from within government
a letter from Liz Trust leaked that was
sent to yourself where she said that
she's worried the UK borders weren't
ready for the end of the transition
period that it could lead to an increase
in smuggling a legal challenge at the
World Trade Organization and even
Northern Ireland's place in the Union
being undermined can you guarantee that
our borders will be ready by the 1st of
January yes
and just a little bit more about the
money that's being announced today
well we're spending seven hundred
million pounds just over seven hundred
million pounds in order to make sure
that our borders can enable the smooth
flow of traffic but also keep us safe
when people voted to take back control
and the referendum three and a half
years ago they wanted us to be in a
position where we could trade with our
neighbors in Europe yes but also have
new trading relationships with other
countries in order to do that that means
that we need to have our borders
upgraded in order to facilitate that
trade it's also the case that we want to
make sure that we can have tough and
secure borders to deal with organized
crime and other security threats and
that's one of the reasons why were
investing in more Border Force personnel
there technology that we're investing in
today will make it easier for people to
do business and also fulfill the promise
of taking back control which people
voted for so given all that then are you
a little bit irritated by Liz Trust if
you replied to our letter
I love Liz have you applied for the
letter I well we don't comment on leaked
documents but Liz and I talk all the
time she's one of my bestest friends in
cabinet okay ringing doors from there
now just finally there are reports this
morning that the government is preparing
to formally announce a u-turn to
actually block the Chinese telecoms firm
why away from involvement in the UK's 5g
network is that true well I can't
comment on that because these decisions
are taken at the National Security
Council and I think it's vitally
important that when these decisions are
taken that the the first people to be
informed afterwards
wherever possible should be the House of
Commons I knew that makes me a bit
old-fashioned wanting to keep this
decision and discussion private and then
have the House of Commons told
afterwards but that's the way I think
things should be done